well we are four days away from super
bowl 55
right here on channel 8. it is the
chiefs versus the bucks in tampa bay
and you can catch the big game only here
on channel 8 it is sunday kickoff
3 30 in the afternoon john very exciting
so
normally the area around the stadium in
tampa any stadium where the super bowl
is
would be packed with fans all week long
that have a fan zone but for obvious
reasons
it's a little quieter this year you know
kevin martin always makes it to these
though and she is live from tampa with a
look at what the vibe is like there
this morning hey kevin how's it going
well good morning alex and john and when
the tampa bay buccaneers were crowned
nfc
champions they created history by
becoming the first team in nfl history
to play the super bowl in their home
stadium and under normal circumstances
we can only imagine the celebration that
would have ensued but of course
these are not normal times but even so
fans are still trying to take advantage
of this rare opportunity
it's different but the world's different
but uh yeah it's not going to
it's not going to dampen our enthusiasm
we're stoked we're fired up
the week leading up to super bowl sunday
is typically six days full of fans
festivities and fun and while tampa is
making the most of the situation
the fans are limited the festivities are
few which can only result
in less fun well obviously we're not
getting the full dose of it
if it was a regular year and there was
no
pandemic going on and the stadium would
be full
obviously it would be chaotic down here
i think that we're missing out a little
bit on the whole experience
you're usually packed and there'll
probably be less people
way less people and usually there's like
a thousand people
probably more but if you only focus on
what this super bowl is lacking
you will miss out on a truly unique and
historic event
with tampa both playing in and hosting
the big game
it's awesome i mean it's a chance of a
lifetime it probably will never happen
again you know it'll be rare if it does
you know
super bowl's only been here five times
and we got one of them and
hopefully we'll walk away with a victory
and while every bucks fan is hoping for
that outcome on sunday
chiefs fans have other thoughts there's
a new guy in town
his name is patrick mahomes and i don't
think that
the bucks have any answer for patrick
mahomes
and yes i think they're going to win
again
the ceo of the super bowl committee rob
higgins said it best he said in part
this is a shot in the arm when we could
use it
it's definitely affected the entire
country but us in particular
it's the super bowl and we needed it the
most
and that's definitely a half glass or
glass half full excuse me
mindset reporting live in tampa kevin
martin 8 sports now
all right kevin thank you very much yeah
a lot of preparations for the game
especially since tampa bay will be in it
everyone's pretty excited for that uh
kevin thank you very much
kevin it looks a little less cold there
this morning too so hopefully uh
you're staying warm in tampa thank you
so much have fun today